I often get asked by value tenor st. Pat
why are we interviewing criminals on
value taemin why mobsters why are you
doing this to us
well here's a reality part of it Richard
Branson the founder of Virgin Airlines
his mother once said Richards either
gonna grow up and be a criminal or he's
going to be a millionaire but it's gonna
be one of those two things you know why
because the one difference between a
Pablo Escobar between the Gotti between
a Mickey Cohen and a Bezos a jobs and an
Elon Musk is they broke the law and the
other entrepreneurs didn't there's a
reason why when you ask many CEOs and
entrepreneurs what is their favorite
movie of all time you'll hear them say
Godfather one and Godfather two you know
why because every element of what a CEO
and an entrepreneur goes through is in
those two movies practically every one
of them - all the killing and all that
other stuff every one of those things an
entrepreneur goes through so let me
cover with you some of the points I got
here that you can learn from some of
these Mafia bosses mobsters and some of
them live in criminals that they build
their empire number one negotiation by
far if there's one thing they are very
good at is negotiation whether it's
negotiation when it's at court
negotiation with their enemies
negotiation with their employees
negotiation with their teams negotiation
with their customers they have to be a
good negotiator in order for them to
make it sometimes they have to negotiate
with an enemy that wants to kill them
and put them out of business it's like
you haven't a negotiate with a
competitor of yours that's locally
putting you out of business how do you
figure out a way to make it work with
them number two they have some of the
most unorthodox strategies that they use
that's not conventional everybody's
trying to do the conventional way they
use different strategies if these guys
were in war there'd be a Napoleon type
of a strategy or a Sun Tzu type of guy
because they don't do what everybody
else does number three surprising their
competition they're famous for
surprising their competition I don't
know where all of a sudden boom
something happens they weren't expecting
this thing to take place you see this
happen in Silicon Valley all the time
you see this happen in business all the
time you see CEOs competitor sport
surprising Chevrolet you'll see this
happen when McDonald's surprising Burger
King or Pepsi surprising coke it happens
all the time the biggest ones do this
all the time number four
they're experts are putting a team
together if you look at somebody a
criminal that goes up and gets the job
done they know it just
about the movie Ocean's eleven do you
notice how many different personalities
that get recruited it's not the same
strength one is technology one is
transportation one is connection one is
the charmer one is the looks one is the
deceive they have so many things that
they know we need a good team to put
together to go out and get the job done
the same happens with businesses well
number five selling a vision they're
always selling a vision number six
paying Commission listen there's story
of Paul Castellano he was known for only
being a business guy and keeping a lot
of the money to himself you know what
eventually happened in front of sparks a
restaurant in New York we all know what
happened he got shot by Gallo Joey Gallo
who was working for Sammy the bull who
was working with John Gotti because he
wasn't willing to pay Commission the
same goes in business I see a lot of
stingy CEOs a lot of stingy sales
representatives that don't pay a lot of
Commission to their people and they're
wondering why they constantly lose their
people you got to pay your people
properly for them to stick around
knowing you take care of them as well
number seven there's a lot of value in
being liquid you see a lot of people
pitching you putting all your money in
every word they didn't work that way
they had cash when things came up they
know how to move the same goes with
bigger companies there's a reason why
Apple is always known for having a lot
of cash Apple is so stingy they have
sixty billion dollars in the bank for
what because I like this they can buy
beats like this they can buy another
company because they have the cash to be
able to do that the same goes with them
as well number eight is keeping your
word if you do not keep your word with
the people you work with in that world
you're not gonna be around for a long
time the same goes with business you
need to build a team around you that you
know if they say they're gonna do
something they come through and pull it
off right number nine it's very very
very big and that's about loyalty you
see they use the word rat that is the
terminology they use and in their world
if they have a rat on their team that
person gets killed by the way in the
world of business if you have a rat in
your company and they go and rat out
numbers of yours to your competitors you
have to fire them immediately before
they put you out of business immediately
enemy of the state
number one is a rat a new company fire
them and move on so now for some of you
that are loyal value Tanner's if you
haven't yet clicked on the alert button
to be alerted every single time to very
timid videos comes out click on that
button if you're a first time buyer
tainer subscribe to this channel once we
cross a million
we're doing our first live value teaming
conference for 25 dates we're all we're
gonna talk about is strategies for you
to take your business to the next level
but we got across a million subs number
10 they have trusted advisors some call
them constantly Aires which means what
it's an advisory board I can go out and
talk to and say should we do this should
we not do this what do you think about
this is this a power play so we put our
money here should we fire this guy what
should we do the same thing go to a
business you got to make sure you have
trusted advisors around you that are
giving you the right direction number 11
collaboration with other families they
find ways to collaborate with other
people hate this business here we're
starting what about if we do this
together and we make money on this and
you make money on this way you bring
help on this side we bring Yelp on this
side that becomes a collaboration hey on
this market over here I know you're good
in this side of the business I'm good at
this side of the business what about we
figure out a way to work together new
collaboration no problem
they're very good at collaboration
especially the ones that go higher and
higher collaboration really all it does
is it speeds up you getting to the top
faster is what it is right next number
12 recruiting their masters are
recruiting they're constantly recruiting
they're constantly selling the dream of
what could happen if you're part of the
family you're gonna get protection
you're gonna be part of it for a long
term we're gonna make a difference we're
gonna have power we're gonna have
freedom we're gonna do all this other
stuff similar things happens in business
when some of those conversations are
happening you better believe when you
work for Google you have a big backing
you better believe when you work for
Apple you got a big backing you better
believe when you're working with Amazon
you got a big back end these things
takes place the same goes with them as
well number thirteen staying ahead of
the curve
they're always curious what's going on
over here what are they doing in this
place
tell me about this part here they have
people that are out there going and
doing foot work maybe you could call it
that but they're going out there
researching hey what if we did this
what's this guy doing what is going on
over here did that guy start a business
are they thinking about opening this new
product did they go into that state did
they go into that new market there's
always that taking place for them to
know what's next in the marketplace so
they can be on there as well number
fourteen face to face communication a
lot of times has this ever happened to
where you text somebody and you're
having a serious conversation but maybe
your level of seriousness is five but
your tone in your text sounds like a
nine the other person's thinking it's a
ten but you're just talking to them as a
five because that's just your tone the
way you text they like face to face
because face to face I don't like it but
this is how I say it
I don't like it and on
says I don't like it it's a big
difference they like to do face to face
let's sit down and figure out a way to
get this thing done right instead of
text next backing each other up you
gotta back me up I'm gonna back you up
if I call a shot you're gonna back me up
if you call a shot because you have a
history of backing me up guess what I am
definitely backing you up but we got to
back each other up because there's a
certain thing about you want a lot of
power you want a lot of influence it
comes with a group of people back in
each other up if you want to be a solo
guy you can be a solo guy but you're
probably not gonna have a lot of backup
right 16 hustle and grind it's
constantly hustle and grinding because
if you don't someone's trying to put you
out of business
same game here the same thing that
happens in the world of business number
17 you got to know the world you live in
what do I mean by this you see criminals
know that there is a thin line between
you and your competitors your
competitors are going to talk to it's
gonna be all good but if they have a way
to get a bigger piece of the pie than
you they're going to do it if they got a
way to get one of your best guys to go
represent them they're probably gonna do
it the same goes in a world of business
you can have a good relationship and a
bond with another seal who's a
competitor but if that guy can get your
best engineer he's probably gonna get
your best engineer that's the line
between competitors Pat Riley can have a
relationship with Popovich but if Pat
Riley has an opportunity to pick up
Kawhi Leonard of course he's gonna do it
that's the same exact thing in the world
that they're in as well as the world in
the world of business 18 willing to
fight for your turf you got a fight
you're gonna be bullied people gonna
push you around and one of the things
about bullies if they bully you you
don't stand up they're gonna do it again
because they know you're afraid but if
they pull you you stand up they're gonna
say we can't mess with this company
number 19 they go for huge payoffs
there's a lot of petty criminals that go
for small things like stealing you know
stuff out of your car for $500 speaker
or stereo sound for what some of these
guys go for the bigger payoffs right I
interviewed Michael Franzese he and one
of the things Michael Franzese do right
now if you go on YouTube you type in the
word mafia on YouTube it's the first
video that typically pops up it'll say
highest-paid mafia boss tells the truth
about the life he went after the oil and
gas business and he started making a lot
of money based on a numbers he sent he
was making an Road between four to eight
million dollars per week as an earner
the point is he went for the bigger
payoff in the world of business if you
go for the smaller payoffs you may make
a 50 grand you may make a hundred
thousand dollars you may make a quarter
million dollars you got to go for the
bigger payoffs is what you got to do
because that's what they're thinking
about as well right number 20 you got to
respect and value other people's assets
just look at what
with Bernie Madoff here's a guy that's
got a reputation in New York everybody
knows this guy massive building I was
there when he went down the day
everybody talked about it but he didn't
respect other people's money he ends up
losing everything that last name the
Madoff last name is so bad his son ended
up committing suicide just because of
fathers decision being made because
there was no respect for other people's
money you don't respect your investors
money when they give you money for your
business guess what happens your new
business go try searching for some other
money later on business it's not gonna
happen because you didn't respect
somebody gave you money to go out and
run your business number 21 creativity
there's creative financing like back in
the days in the mortgage business they
used to say we do create a financing I
kept saying what is creative financing
well we do create a finance and let's
just say we can get you proof for this
million-dollar room but tell me what you
mean about is creative financing
look listen instead of saying you make
180 thousand dollars we can put six
hundred twenty thousand dollars instead
of saying you have fifty thousand
dollars in America can tell me at five
hundred thousand dollars in a bank we
can do create a financing don't worry
about it that's not what I'm talking I
would create a finances I'm talking
about there's creative ways get your
business positioned in a way that has an
edge over your competitors by the way
Elon Musk is creative Jobs is creative
Bezos is creative they found creative
ways to position themselves to move up
their empire whatever industry they were
in so they compete with the marketplace
but you got to get creative number 22
rituals criminals have rituals do you
think about Mafia families they have
rituals there's certain things that you
do you don't cross the line with this
you don't do this with that you don't do
anything with the wives you don't do
anything with the sisters you don't do
anything with the daughters there are
certain rituals you file on the same
goes with business every company I know
has certain rituals that cannot be
broken when you work over here at the
home office we have certain rituals any
time I bring new executives one of the
first things we talk about is these are
the rituals we follow do you have any
problems with these rituals and that one
thing is a little bit weird I know it's
weird but I want to tell you upfront
because we're not compromising this this
is who we are are you okay with that
yeah I'm okay with that but it is a
little bit weird I understand but it's
what we're doing same goes with that as
well in the world of business number 23
having a succession plan who's getting
power next after you who's gonna run the
show after you are you already looking
for it do you know what you're looking
for do you know what's gonna happen when
you're no longer there you know who's
gonna run the company do you know if you
give it to your 28 year old son who is
has no clue what it is to work 80 hours
a week is just daddy's son but he wants
to come
run the company do you know that 60%
your employees are gonna leave if you
give it to them do you know that is it
too early it's a timing what do you want
to do what are people saying about it
have you gone to school
have you read the books have you had an
advisor tell you how to properly do a
succession plan have you spoken to three
people that did it the right way three
people that did it the wrong way are you
prepared for all that other stuff if you
are great if you're not this is what
happens when a succession plan has gone
wrong company collapses because the
power was given to the wrong person
following the original founder 24 lead
by example chief you do it right you'll
have your nephew your niece your kids
your daughters your family people will
say I want to grow up and have the kind
of influence that my auntie has I want
to grow up and I want to be an
entrepreneur like my uncle I want to
grow up and be like my father I want to
grow up and be like my sister I want to
grow up and be like my brother because
you've done it right where you've set
the example for somebody else want to
follow your footsteps and last but not
least out-of-control greed this is one
thing you gotta learn what I mean by
out-of-control greed everybody is greedy
I don't know a single person that's not
greedy everybody is greedy in every
aspects of our lives were greedy and by
the way every time you talk about the
topic of greed someone's always gonna
tell you I'm not that greedy everybody
else is greedy
everybody's greedy to a level but then
there's a different level of greed and
by the way this next level of greed is
what typically follows a massive fall
and legacy collapses you gotta know if
you're getting close to that out of
control greed because sometimes you may
not even know about it they're getting
to this place here because typically
when you get to this place here these
things shut off you don't listen to
anybody all you're doing is listening to
yourself you just hear you don't hear
anybody else right when you get to that
level when you get too out of control
greed you have to be so careful because
like this the 22 years have you put into
this business to build it can be gone
there's seven years of 80 hour weeks you
put into that business can be gone
because I'm out of control greed you got
to make sure you have those things in
place as well okay so hopefully now you
have an idea why I interview people that
I don't necessarily agree with
politically lifestyle wise even if it's
a criminal because what I've learned
over the years I don't just learn from
people that do it the right way I always
like to learn also from people that did
it wrong so I know what not to do to
sustain my momentum to keep my business
going to the next level now for some of
you that are famous were telling us why
we're interviewing all these people and
saying I can't believe you just
interviewed this guy why don't you have
this
value payment here's what I want you to
do I want you to tweet me at Patrick bid
David and tell me exactly who you want
us to interview and tag them as well
with their handle it could be anybody if
it's Elon Musk let's have a thousand
people tweet at Elon Musk and say Pat we
want to see Elon Musk on very tame and
well they will go out there and get them
but they gotta hear it and we got to
hear from you as well and last but not
least for some of you guys that are
saying what happened to the PDF that
Mario prepares click on the link below
here to go out and get the PDF free on
our website and print it out and see
what are some of these areas that you
can implement on your business to help
you take you to the next level take
everybody bye-bye
[Music]